da waste udai è talmente conosciuto che
ho detto prima poi ci farò un video non
ho la più pallida idea di che cosa sto
per andare a giocare ma va bene la prima
cosa che notiamo ragazzi una salsiccia
che sculetta e direi che il gioco parla
da sé che sarà doppia il play game stop
the blood è ferma al sangue e solo io
non sto capendo una sega di quello che
succede tra sport al rene dopo farebbe
ti sto gioco ma devo anche girarlo e va
bene
poverino ma cosa sto vedendo
ma cos'è faster sembra il gioco di qua
no vabbè ma è impossibile a io devo
evitare che sta gente si suicidi tabs
loculi
[Musica]
cosa sto vedendo rega che cos'è sta roba
multe cup field line va bene a sei morto
perché hai bevuto troppo va bene ho
capito non so come ho fatto a vivere e
respirare o qualsiasi altra cosa abbia
fatto nella vita senza aver prima
giocato a questo gioco non so come ho
fatto bene e quindi la trama sembra aver
capito bene ci sono questi omini che
sembrano tipo quelli di happy tree
friends che tentano di suicidarsi e tu
devi evitare questa cosa defender the
pride park di fendi le parti intime
va bene ma non ce l'hai le parti intime
non c'è niente li sotto lui è una parte
intima tutto il corpo lo è se sembra
molto ambiguo ma è così don't let forte
e va bene insieme cosa devo fare un
soffiare sull'ipad dimmelo tu lo so che
casino faster drag e tap d'equipe ma un
attimo sto leggendo simhara che hanno
disco ma no non è possibile anche a
leggere ma porca eva playgame forza a
volte baseball non riescono ancora
leggere cosa devo fare un attimo ok devo
ok ho capito perfetta adesso la mamma
mia che ansia perfetto se cade volumi
investiva il treno spiega proprio a
questi giorni giochi da premi nobel sto
facendo è proprio visto superando molte
carattere brolo yellow line ok non
sorpassare la linea gialla
va bene run veloce cosa mi rappresentava
stranieri hanno spiegato i tappi fresh
food solo quello era il facebook ma
perché perché vi fa cristiano ronaldo
con la torta spiega il faster tappe
destri ancora singh ha dovuto appare
quando quando era sulle strisce va bene
ma perché volevo capire bene come si
fanno i livelli perché alcuni non riesco
neanche a realizzare in tempo cosa devo
fare capito quindi normale che io perda
madonna un piccione in bocca ho preso
che se avessi detto un uccello sarebbe
stato molto ambiguo pro 1600 e 70
addirittura non è male per un nome non
ci ha mai giocato direi ma poi costruire
il tuo fagiolo ma che bello ma guarda
dire che quei capelli ci siamo anche ma
facevate vediamo il resto ho provato a
farlo somigliare il più possibile a me
ma non è che così tanto prova è meglio
di niente play game
proviamoci di nuovo raga ok mon 2018 va
benissimo cosi
find the psycho ma è gesù venerdì 13 da
questi dai bellissimo apn sapiens
pazienza technics file è duale freni
quello che non è scaduta cav h non sono
capace ragionare in fretta malapena so
come mi chiamo maledizione coverde panov
it but cavalca ma vi pare
manco fossi cannavacciuolo perché
dovresti dare del bacon on un serpente
spiega anche problemi ai faster dark
sono uscito mi serino quelli che conosco
già sono una cagata da fare quelli che
non conoscono capire come si fanno prima
di ellis ok
manca una tesi non sia capace scaduto
porca eva morta morta scaduta ma fan
correva la data deve essere avanzata al
calendario che minchia sono un
deficiente gente de toast
ok poi perché dovresti prenderlo con una
forchetta propria lasciamo perdere swipe
to avoid praga io faccio veramente
schifo in studio che non so se si è
notato connect the ball ma perché un
treno ma cosa c'entrano i treni cosa
c'entra il treno c'erano i palloncini
spiegami in qualche ora che arriva la
devo superare 1070 punto ammettiamo star
da perfetto ma perché lo dai a serpente
ogni volta che fastidio
no ok no destroy the asteroids va bene
fatto perché sono tutti i fagioli
personaggi visto gioco per come lo
spiega chi per un attimo madonna che
nervi che non capisco cosa devo fare in
tempo già può averne un attimo ma un
secondo che fastidio
faster difenderò questo sono stato lo fa
quelli dove che sai cosa devi fare e
sono anche agatina immonda super chiaro
mai però quanto tempo ce l'ho fatta
scrivo fatto va bene e da e lui danza
vabbè nome descartes field line buona e
giusta giusto come la messa poca ma da
va a cagare sono reginal con non è colpa
mia zio scusami quei 100 forza gira gira
madonna che fastidio
ok va bene pd o del whale ok perfetto
dai raga devo arrivarci 1070 miss non
devo mai morire è difficilissima ma ci
provo
ok altre due ragazze 329 stavamo sa fare
aiuto no mi chiama che sono lentissimo
porco demonio ma cos'è così difficile
minchia c'è mica il gioco delle formine
i bambini non riesco a farlo ogni volta
voglio qua porca eva morta ma dai
no ma perché non riesco pregare ogni
volta lì che fastidio
dov'è lo psycho rosa ecco non lo trovo
regalo non trovano lo trovano lo trovo
eva pietro lapidato perché non riesco a
fare una roba per bambini fare lo prende
il casco il casco l'ho fatta e non
conosciamo il livello incredibile
questa è tanta roba è rega fede quando
dalla scala sono ricasca perfetto un
2018 a voi ragazzi o ascolta stiamo
andando benissimo e stop the blood
ok draga non ci arriverò mai a mille io
lo so dai 900 ma edizione ancora uno
spessore di aster ha reso al conosco la
conosco pista che gioca in casa la
conosciamo re villari 15 l'ho fatto lo
stesso tav crossing suscita batte allo
stesso record incredibile nonostante
fossi morto va bene
[Musica]
perfetto
intercasino cuore gala a cagare ma vai a
cagare mori c'è non è possibile
va bene 1228 normale ragazzi non male
come giuro solennemente di non fare
cagate vicino ai treni prometto cos'è
sta roba
va bene così sono soddisfatto della
persona che sono anche ero soddisfatto
anche prima di giocasta roba per carità
però va bè ragazzi miei spero che vi sia
piaciuto è una figata dumb ways to die
non conoscevano anche il gameplay però
era da un po che volevo farlo e sono
finalmente riuscito a farlo spero che vi
semplicità ragazzi come stesso giorno
momento mi piace anche per i soci ha
commentato descrizione sempre si chiede
e noi ci vediamo l'anno prossimo visto
dai ragazzi
[Musica]